[Music]
in changing times news submitted by a
fool the cipher what's up almost half of
all US births now have happen outside of
mariage mmm wait lock babies so light I
bought the baby but I don't have a
marriage baby I guess you know this host
that would have been shocking like 3040
years ago Forks are working hard
dropping off babies left and right
well it's funny you say that so they're
saying that 48 so now it's 40% of all
births in the US occur outside of with
the bastards from 10 percent in 1970 I'm
not qualified to answer that question
bastard in a basket that qualified I
just thought there will be blood it's
just saw Black Dynamite yes I [ __ ]
love that movie no dude I didn't seen
that movie in ages I forgot all about it
so good the funniest [ __ ] movie I've
ever seen in my life yeah it's Black
Dynamite yeah oh is it like this
Superfly parody kind of yeah Michael Jai
White like you like co-wrote it too
which is so are they does he have an
orange drink and then he's in is like
Cadillac and [ __ ] no but that's another
one no the second the second one isn't
Black Dynamite but it's another one of
those movies start sorry Michael a bit
Oh did its sofa I was in tears laughing
there's a trailer for the thing right
now yeah obviously black that inmate no
hilarious do any movie where you [ __ ]
chest kick an old lady in this stuff
dude that's like that kicking video we
were watching man I [ __ ] die during
that man I loved it anyway yeah these
are births oh wait wait wait so what's
going on is it like a problem or is it
just like supply it's an observation
people [ __ ] popping up
it's just like a sign of the times
because now people aren't so focused on
like oh we need to get married we have
to get married first before having kids
now there's a lot of these now there's a
lot of people who just should never have
kids and they're having kids you know
that we in long-term relation and they
still live together everything is just
without the you know the paper without
the $60,000 that they spend on the
wedding yeah I know somebody right and
that's not including the ring by the way
a lot of people are more and more
opposed to marriage lately I've noticed
yeah well maybe with something for a
long time I want that tax break so why
not take cash yeah you might as well if
that really anything yeah yeah you need
it for when she divorces you like a
savings account fee money well that's
the question is is marriage a bad
investment cuz a longing to find out
Steve don't know so far it's been
working out right I mean so far so he
helped you save money to buy mine oh
dude if I don't have her I wouldn't say
that anything mmm she's like you would
owe like fifty million dollars in tax he
owed like thirteen thousand dollars and
I was like how have you not paid and I
was like the real question is how am I
not in federal prison my dad is a CPA
hey why don't you do this he did like 30
minutes that guy is a legend David is
crazy
yeah and then he would never have bought
a house like you know rushed or urgency
or I had no plan no nothing man accuse
my money manager dude it's awesome
I'm so goal-oriented I'm like awesome
really am we like open up different
accounts of like okay everyone or
putting money into these accounts but we
want to buy a house event box that a
hundred percent invest all day every day
crypto baby all day day go corn a
realist a whatever take my chances case
in point bet Queen
I feel about that right now I feel great
about it feel bad you want to explain to
everyone else in the comments why you
feel so good about it still um yeah cuz
I'm up a thousand percent on my initial
investment in this show but what about
the most recent no because look look we
have to think about like this when I
bought Bitcoin it was 2013
right this was back when Bitcoin was a
thousand bucks each so after that the
market tanked ass all the way down to
125 bucks per Bitcoin right and I never
sold and everyone thought I was a
[ __ ] idiot my buddy Mike thought it
was like dude you're [ __ ] idiot buyer
this big Quinn [ __ ] make you thought I
was India buy this Bitcoin [ __ ] right
well then a couple years go by I buy
this new one called aetherium
when it was ten bucks each now that then
that [ __ ] went to [ __ ] 1,300 bucks
each right and now it's down to 200
bucks
so I'm still way too [ __ ] up on when I
bought it's just a matter of you have to
wait the mark gets out cuz markets go up
and down I think that's just I'm sure
that new currency a new a new way of
doing things
yeah when and that's a very small window
of time versus like how long crypto has
already been out exactly and less than
8% of people in the world even own
crypto so the idea that the bubble is
burst and all the [ __ ] to me it's like
when the microwave came out right like
it was adopted on a global scale and the
hockey stick went up like that so to me
it's just the stuff as it becomes useful
and usable it will get adopted that's
why I'm on board now in front of him
back then yeah yeah yeah I'm still
making fun of Joe but it's funny I'll
gladly put my foot in my mouth when
we're rich yes oh yeah yeah you know
we're gonna take trips and I would be in
first class and you're gonna be with the
chickens I'm gonna freeze
and put her in like a sleeping like
you're like when we're rich and he's
like oh yes I said we still gonna put
her back by only crypto regret is that I
didn't put a [ __ ] ton of money into it
like I wish I put in their shitload of
money yeah that's my biggest regret I
believe from the start if you didn't
believe that you'll get another rewards
cuz you didn't believe it so it doesn't
exist
that's my what my we believed it when
you initially did it and then it way
actually first it for extra work you
know there's all those like oh by
December it's gonna be great
and then it's like oh and by the way
when in a couple years from now when
people are able to like drive like uber
and lyft right but they don't have to go
through over and let because
everything's on the blockchain and
you're able to pay like for some UI some
user interface that directly accepts
uses crypto to exchange funds for people
and they're not gonna need to like go to
some call centre or get directed at
where to go like they'll all be free
software that you download just like how
you download a free browser and it'll
link you with with writers and it'll
you'll pay for it with crypto I always
think your hands are gonna smack me the
world is gonna change in a huge way both
you guys have a risk for some reason
when you guys are rich I feel like
you're gonna adopt me as a child
yep but we're gonna treat you like your
child yes yes we will yell at you all
check this out though I'll never get
yelled at
oh you know what you really yell at me
okay that's pretty good when won't won't
work we rich will get a warehouse and
make the best [ __ ] kitchen ever that
has everything and it will have
ingredients [ __ ] there like every
[ __ ] day and we would just brainstorm
and [ __ ] create different Oh
the use money dojo heaven can you do the
gastronomy foods yet it's like bone
foods like salt foam and like oh that's
this year we had as you all know like
[ __ ] like that is because number one
isn't that sustenance number two is it's
just fancy [ __ ] and there's stuff with
flavor analysis is the only kind of
gastronomy I like is root beer float top
[Music]
Hana me so you're not gonna have
children out of wedlock I would but I'm
pretty sure Merrill is not down with it
but I would if I could afford it yeah so
you wouldn't marry me first
yeah you would oh yeah because then if I
get tax deductible that we could really
afford it what I'm the only one here
that has had a child oh yeah so I can
tell you it's fine you know it's great
you're like not really a big deal but
was it a big deal that's great kid it
was a choice it was it was a choice I
supposed to get pregnant at 17 I was
freaking crazy it was a dumb choice but
it was a choice I was a very dumb - it
worked out great he got a do big little
son I was born in wedlock but it was a
shotgun wedding cuz they did they were
planning on having me quite yet I plan
if you guys have a kid outside of
wedlock
I plan on anonymously calling you in the
middle of the night and going you're
going to hell and hanging up we're gonna
have a shotgun wedding wait the shotgun
wedding is when the branch is already
pregnant yeah yeah oh that was my
parents yeah how long was like three
months pregnant because you can't have
the village know that [ __ ] yeah well my
mom was like very she was clearly
showing like I was in the wedding
pictures for sure my mom who she would
tell me when I was little she was like
you were so good on the day of our
wedding like you were just like so
tucked in there so nice and like you
just were hiding from everyone and then
that night we took off the dress you
just popped right out
oh I picture your with your face in your
mom stomach like
flat bielagus all like that your mom
helping hook and your mom up then she
and this year's we're home and then and
then you're like oh I was sucking in for
a long time it was a long one that's why
you like tight small spaces [ __ ] I know
my mother used to look good that's true
I do love tight spaces like so much I
had my bedroom in my walk-in closet once
when I was a kid oh my god how much I
love Harry Potter [ __ ] yeah I like that
too I've always thought it was amazing
November birthday thing
it was like people are like oh it's a
Scorpio thing whatever but um like
having like little Kate caves or like
something that's like like a dog just
for me that nobody knows where I am and
it's just like tiny boy I used to hide
in the closet between all the black
Mexican big plus like fluffy blanket my
mouth stopped working he's like hide in
there and one time my mom called the
cops because she couldn't find me and
they're like cops like cuz I fell asleep
oh thank you for my name and I was just
like nice and my cats do that and you
just came out from the closet that's
amazing found me in the closet or your
birthday I'm gonna get a really bad big
[ __ ] like vacuum seal plastic
FoodSaver thing and you're gonna get
inside put a straw in there [ __ ] poke
a hole you can breathe that [ __ ] I'm
gonna turn that [ __ ] on and that'll feel
extra codes want you to get ur blankets
in there that's get her [ __ ] tent
dude then she can breathe in there Jesus
did you ever do that in a Mike Ross or
whatever going like the clothing racks
remember they had their like circle
[Music]